coming up on 5 55 on your friday morning
hey we're talking the talk we're walking
the walk
at the 95 in the northern 215 beltway
come on along we're going
centennial bowling
so instead of all my weekly yammering
about this massive project you want to
see what it's going to look like when
it's done
three years from now it's very
visually stunning sam lytle from the 3d
rendering company civil effects isn't
kidding
like it's one thing for me to keep
saying that oso blanca is going to run
under the 215. it's something else
all together to see it as it's going to
look
same goes for the extension of sky point
under
the flyover from west 215 to the south
95
but over the beltway on the east side of
the 95.
you can not only see the project's
growth from nothing
to flashing colors showing the different
phases along the way
and the centennial bowl is not all about
cars
when they say multi-use trail across the
95 they're not kidding
walkers joggers and bicyclists going to
find a lot to explore
so you can review the online version of
this and all our centennial bowl stories
with a link to that
very cool animation video at
8newsnow.com when you click traffic then
driving you crazy
buckle up drive carefully please put
down that phone if there is something
driving you crazy email me traffic 8
8newsnow.com